[Musique]
et on a appris que Jean-Philippe lu le
maire de boisdarcy annoncé sa démission
sur sur dans une lettre publiée sur
facebook j'allais dire sur Twitter
c'était sur facebook oui exactement dans
son communiqué l'élu fait référence à
son activité professionnelle les
conditions ne sont malheureusement plus
réunies pour que je puisse terminer mon
mandat sereinement notamment car mon
activité professionnelle que j'ai
toujours souhaité poursuivre me demande
de plus en plus de temps il évoque aussi
un mandat particulièrement difficile
suite à la la crise sanitaire
énergétique et inflationniste euh
Jean-Philippe lu était devenu maire de
Bois d'Arcy en novembre 2020
ledadressera sa démission au préfet des
Yvelines dans les 15 jours suivant la
démission du maire le conseil municipal
devra se réunir afin de procéder à
l'élection d'un nouveau maire et de et
de ses adjoints pardon je m'étouffe dans
l'actualité de ce mardi 6 février
également Clara cette nouvelle
mobilisation des enseignants une grève
qui était à l'appel de des principaux
syndicats d'enseignants oui et le
mouvement national a été suivi dans les
Yvelines parmi les établissements
mobilisés le collège de La Coudre à
Montini le Bretonneux où selon le
collectif des enseignants 70 % d'entre
eux ont répondu au préavis de greffe
déposé ce mardi parmi leurs
revendication le manque de moyens
humains leurs conditions de travail ou
encore la perte de moyens horaires de
l'établissement Gabriel Gontier était
sur place ça fait plusieurs années qu'on
perd des moyens horaires sur notre
dotation cette année on perd à nouveau
6h50 de dotation horaire en heure
d'enseignement pour nos élèves et tout
cela associé aux nouvelles directives
avec des groupes de niveau en 6e et en
5e en mathématique et en français fait
qu'on perd plus d'une vingtaine d'heure
d'enseignement pour nos
élèves parmi les enseignants cette
baisse de la de la dotation horaire
globale menace également certains cours
et sections au sein de l'établissement
le fait que il y ait des groupes de
niveau ça va forcément impacter toutes
les autres matières à savoir que tous
les demi-roupes qui étaient mis en place
qu'on appelle la paix ça va en fait être
complètement déstructuré il n'y aura
plus de demi-groupe alors que nous avons
des effectifs d'environ 30 élèves par
classe donc ça implique plus de travaux
pratique des séances en salle
informatique qui sont impossibles en
mathématique en technologie dans toutes
les
matières en réponse à ce mouvement les
enseignant ont obtenu un rendez-vous
prochainement avec la directrice
académique des services de l'éducation
nation aucune information n'a été donnée
pour le moment concernant la
reconduction du mouvement on parle à
présent avec vous des nouvelles mesures
du rapport d'Iv Ramet ça concerne la
ligne B du RER le but c'est de réduire
les retards et donc c'est ces
préconisations sont mises en place par
île- de France mobilité la SNCF et la
RATP depuis 7ette semaine oui pour
rappel ce rapport avait été commandé en
2023 par Valérie pces président
d'île-de-fance mobilité et de la région
Île-de-France l'objectif était de mettre
en place un plan plan d'action pour
améliorer le service du RERB et gagner
un point de ponctualité par an jusqu'en
2025 pour cela elle a notamment mandaté
ivramet expert ferroviaire et ancien
directeur général de la RATP 14 mesures
concrètes ont alors été définies
certaines sont déjà mises en place parmi
les nouveautés le RERB dispose de six
trains supplémentaires aptes à rouler
l'ensemble des trains seront aussi doté
de plusce GPS pour mieux gérer le parc
en exploitation et pour mieux traiter
les incidents les les conducteurs de
train sont autorisés depuis juin 2023 à
rouler au pas lorsque je cite une
intrusion non avérée est signalée selon
nos confrère du Parisien Laurent
souvignier directeur de la ligne du RERB
affirme que les chiffres du mois de
janvier sont encour encourageant 86,7 %
des trains étaient à l'heure ce mois-ci
contre 82,9 % en janvier 2023 il est il
était àarré au qu des 20 de Limet depuis
2008 le Yach de Churchill va quitter les
i puisquil a été vendu à un
collectionneur anglais l'Amazon de son
vrai nom va retrouver sa terre natale au
sud de l'Angleterre le Yach dont la
légende dit qu'il a appartenu à Wiston
Churchill a leveré les voiles ce lundi 5
février vers 11h il sera d'abord
remorqué jusqu'au port du Havre avant de
traverser la Manche sur un
semiubmersible son nouveau propriétaire
serait un riche anglais dont l'identité
n'a pas été dévoilée et concernant le
prix de vente le prix de vente même
chose le chiffre reste un mystère en
2016 le prix était fixé à 1,9 million
d'euros avant de descendre à 600000 €
quoi qu'il arrive on parle d'une grosse
somme on termine en musique Lara ce
weekend avait lieu la finale du
trempelin des voix c'était à la Maison
de l'Environnement de maniléamo
exactement 20 candidats étaient en liste
pour le concours de champ national à la
clé des heures de coaching et des suivis
personnalisés parmi les lauréas de cette
9e édition on retrouve loudeleuse qui
remporte la première place dans la
catégorie 17 ans et moins STL remporte
quant à elle le prix de la meilleure
interprète dans la catégorie 18 ans et
plus et enfin li a obtenu le premier
prix dans la catégorie auteur
compositeur interprète voici quelques
extraits de leur prestation
[Musique]
voy plus
lo je me suis cassé la gueule en tombant
sous ton charme dans un tapis de fleurs
Arom bravo gagnant de cette 9e édition
du Tremplin des voies et Merci à VOUS
Clara de Frutos pour ces informations et
comme d'habitude si vous aussi près de
chez vous vous êtes témoin d'une
actualité qui vous fait réagir dans les
ivelines n'hésitez pas à la partager sur
les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 7 news